uh it wasn't this season but it was last
year it was here
um there was an incident between the
Heat and the nuggets and you guys were
so upset that you were in the hallway
and I understand but what I'm asking is
are there any hard feelings that linger
from that night and do you think they
could spill out in the series I don't
think so I think there's a lot of
like
stuff about the whole situation that
people don't understand
um
and I'll let that you know stay back
there
but I don't think it has too much to do
with anything it's thing of the past
high level competition but I will say uh
I wasn't talking
to jokic that wasn't my beef so make
sure you write that and the individual
who I was talking to definitely know who
I was talking to